serious question spoiler in Jurassic
Park what's naturally under some kind of
a deadline to get those embryos smuggled
out because otherwise why choose the
night of a tropical storm with tourists
on the island for the first time dude
you control the whole park take a rain
check try again tomorrow so you crashed
your Jeep in a ravine take a mulligan
Neumann hello John would the real John
Hammond have had to interact with
himself
every single time tourists did the
automatic tour ride it only works if
he's talking to himself did he have to
hire a staff of John Hammond
impersonators did they clone John
Hammond so what happens if you pay a
visit to Jurassic Park and no dinosaurs
show up you know kind of like what
happened with the test group do you get
a refund do you get a rain check and why
are all of the dinosaur cages so packed
with foliage it's a zoo don't you want
people to see them Susie or not Susie
that is the question
in lost world wouldn't you need a lot of
permits before putting a dinosaur zoo in
San Diego he says they're planning to
open in like less than a month the city
council really signed off on this role
in the game hunter has a single earring
on his right ear is this the closest
we'll come to garrison tation in the
franchise or does it count that all the
dinosaurs are bred to be female and
still start families together
why was Jeff Goldblum's daughter cut
from the gymnastics team school cut you
from the team I'd like to see Simone
biles kick a rapper through a window hey
in Jurassic Park 3 what was dr. Grant's
first name again oh yeah this is a t-rex
pee I've got a theory let a t-rex piss
on you release the t-rex pee tape
shouldn't Alan be more concerned about
those 3 Pteranodons flying toward the
mainland at the end I can't bring a
papaya back from Hawaii but the flying
lizard monsters get a pass
so in Jurassic world we're supposed to
believe that the general population is
bored with Dinosaurs
I mean people still go to zoos right
it's not like little kids get bored with
tigers and monkeys and stuff what
happened to Isla Sorna it's a whole
other dinosaur island are we just gonna
pretend that lost world in Jurassic Park
3 never happened yes so they designed a
new dinosaur to boost attendance and yet
they made it invisible how am i taking a
selfie with that story
so these gyres tears can be piloted off
the rails by guests around the entire
park they're rolling into restricted
areas and I can't even take one freakin
shopping cart out of the Whole Foods
parking lot okay
fallen kingdom you're telling me they
built a theme park on an island with an
active volcano twice that is a really
big oversight if you're gonna spare no
expense maybe hire a geologist Jimmy
Fallon
why didn't I and Malcom testify for the
Senate lying across the table with his
shirt unbuttoned that seems a lot more
like it's done it's now been two movies
of people talking about sending
dinosaurs into war zones and we haven't
seen one armored dinosaur eating
terrorists when are we gonna get to the
fireworks factory and buy fireworks
factory I mean a Dino riders movie so
how do I get invited to a black-market
dinosaur auction is there a mailing list
is there a secret handshake do we do
orgy mass I'm just trying to get the
feel here four million dollars seems
awfully cheap for a live dinosaur then
again how do you even start to set a
baseline price for a dinosaur do you
just check what Tigers are selling for
and add a couple of zeros what would a
slovenian arms dealer want with a
personal murder dinosaur what kind of
operation is this guy running where a
raptor would be better than like a guy
with a gun
he wants to assassinate a rival via
Raptor attack well I guess it would send
a message also after your Raptor
finishes killing its target how do you
get her back into her cage we never saw
a signal for go back home and don't kill
me or anyone else or get noticed by the
cops it's gonna be in part three so when
the little girl lets all the dinosaurs
out at the end that's basically murder
right yes after two movies do we
actually know anything about Owen Grady
or is played by Chris Pratt enough of
the character trick I don't know he
likes vests could rocky beat up a
dinosaur yeah I could
you
[Music]